Let us now revisit the second
calculation that we carried
out in the context of
our earlier example.
In that example, we calculated
the total probability of an
event that can occur under
different scenarios.
And it involves the powerful
idea of divide and conquer
where we break up complex
situations
into simpler pieces.
Here is what is involved.
We have our sample space.
And our sample space is
partitioned into a number of
subsets or events.
In this picture we take that
number to be 3, so we'll have
it partitioned into three
possible scenarios.
It is a partition which means
that these events cover the
entire sample, space
and they're
disjoint from each other.
For each one of the scenarios
we're given their
probabilities.
If you prefer, you can also
draw this situation
in terms of a tree.
There are three different
scenarios that can happen.
We're interested in a particular
event, B. That
event B can happen in three
different ways.
It can happen under scenario
one, under scenario two, or
under scenario three.
And this corresponds to these
particular sub-events.
So for example, this
is the event
where scenario A1 happens.
And then event B happens
as well.
In terms of a tree diagram, the
picture becomes as follows.
If scenario A1 materializes,
event B may occur or event B
might not occur.
Finally, we are given
conditional probabilities that
event B will materialize under
each one of the different
possible scenarios.
Under those circumstances, can
we calculate the probability
of event B?
Of course we can.
And here's how we do it.
First we realize that event
B consists of a number of
disjoint pieces.
One piece is when event B occurs
together with event A1.
Another piece is when event
B occurs together with A2.
B occurs together with A3.
These three sets are disjoint
from each other, as we see in
this picture.
And together they form the
event B. Therefore, the
probability of B is going to be,
by the additivity axiom of
probabilities, equal to the sum
of the probabilities of
these sub-events.
Furthermore, for each one of
these sub-events we can use
the multiplication rule
and write their
probabilities as follows.
The probability that B and A1
both occur is the probability
that scenario one materializes
times the conditional
probability that B occurs
given that A1 occurred.
And then we're going to have
similar terms under the second
scenario and a similar term
under the third scenario.
So putting everything together,
we have arrived at a
formula of this form.
The total probability of event
B is the sum of the
probabilities of the different
ways that B may occur, that
is, B occurring under the
different scenarios.
And those particular
probabilities are the product
of the probability of the
scenario times the conditional
probability of B given
that scenario.
Now, note that the sum of the
probabilities of the different
scenarios is of course
equal to 1.
And this is because the
scenarios form a partition of
our sample space.
So if we look at this formula
here, we realize that it is a
weighted average of the
conditional probabilities of
event B, weighted average of the
conditional probabilities
where these probabilities of the
individual scenarios are
the weights.
In words, the probability that
an event occurs is a weighted
average of the probability
that it has under each
possible scenario, where the
weights are the probabilities
of the different scenarios.
One final comment--
our derivation was for the
case of three events.
But you can certainly see that
the same derivation would go
through if we had any finite
number of events.
But even more, if we had a
partition of our sample space
into an infinite sequence of
events, the same derivation
would still go through, except
that in this place in the
derivation, instead of using the
ordinary additivity axiom
we would have to use the
countable additivity axiom.
But other than that, all the
steps would be the same.
And we would end up with the
same formula, except that now
this would be an infinite
sum over the
infinite set of scenarios.